did you ever wonder what would happen if
these characters had devil fruits which
one would be the best fit for them and
how strong would they be afterwards well
after going through more than a hundred
different devil fruits I found the
perfect ones and where better to start
than with Legendary Pirate King Goldie
Roger Roger was known to be an
Unstoppable force with his ridiculously
powerful hockey and from what we can
tell he has seemingly never lost a
battle before so if Roger was already
this strong did you ever wonder what
would happen if he ever ate a devil
fruit if we want to theorize what could
happen in this scenario we first need to
figure out which devil fruit would be
best suited for him instead of
mentioning just one let's take a look at
two starting with none other than the
one his son eight the metamera no me
besides the regular logia abilities this
fruit grants the user I think Roger
would find other unique ways to use it
for example The Meta metanomi could work
so well in combination with his
legendary sword Ace possibly allowing
him to carry out fiery long-range
attacks on opponents before they even
come close to him it would also allow
him to travel faster and he could even
engage his opponents at light lightning
speeds using the Flames as a type of
engine launch pad for his feet okay I
know this looks ridiculous but each
Roger we're talking about here it's not
really hard to imagine that he'd try
something like this the other devil
fruit I wanted to talk about is
gumagomonomi or as it's secretly known
me model Nika this mythical Zone devil
fruit is the biggest threat to the world
government and a legendary fruit linked
to Joy boy so why would this route be
the best choice for Roger well
throughout the series it was shown
multiple times that Roger and Luffy
share a lot of similar traits from their
laid-back personality to straight up
saying the same things and even their
mutual love for hitting the Subscribe
button okay maybe not that last one but
you should definitely click it thanks
anyway it's only natural that they also
have the same devil for you Roger would
certainly unlock the Awakening of the
fruit during his adventures same as
Luffy did which means that he'd have not
only the rubber abilities but also the
reality warping potential of its
awakened form by the way I just made a
sun god drawing of Roger for this video
and you have to admit he looks so cool
so after reviewing doing both fruits
which would be the better choice for
Roger in my opinion it's definitely the
gumagoma Nomi due to its ties to Luffy
and joyboy but flaming Roger would be
sick too
Zorro the vice captain of the straw hat
Pirates is a master swordsman who will
stop at nothing to achieve his dream of
becoming the strongest swordsman in the
world his unique fighting style consists
of wielding three katanas simultaneously
and it is known as the three sword style
so the ideal fruit for zotto would
probably work around this fighting style
in some way and enhance it at first
glance the obvious choice would be Mr
one's fruit super supernomi which allows
users to convert body parts into blades
this could work really well for zoto in
some cases for example when he's
completely missing his swords or needs
one more to complete his stance however
the downside to this fruit is that these
swords would be much weaker than his
usual swords like enma or shusui and
therefore with greatly limit his
abilities other than this one we could
consider some logia type fruits for Zoro
since those would help increase his
overall abilities but let's make it a
bit more interesting and give him a
fruit that most of you have never even
unheard of this fruit is currently
unnamed but it's wielded by the Marine
vice admiral onigumo this devil fruit
seemingly is some kind of spider Zone
and allows its user to have six extra
arms appear from their back this route
would be perfect for zoto as he'd be
able to hold nine blades at the same
time just imagine all the extra
techniques he could come up with now
some of you may say that Zoro can
already use nine sword style while
utilizing ashida but the difference here
is that he wouldn't drain so much energy
each time he activates it another
Advantage would be that zodo could find
even more legendary swords throughout
the one piece world and use them all at
the same time I don't know about you
guys but I don't think we'll ever find a
more fitting fruit for Zoro there's
still six interesting characters left to
cover and the next one is zoro's biggest
obstacle dracul mihawk mihawk is the
world's strongest swordsman and is
actually the first warlord that we were
introduced to in the series his main
weapon is a gigantic sword named yaru
and based on the little fighting we've
seen from him he seems to be easily an
emperor level fighter mihawk is clearly
inspired by the legendary vampire
Dracula with his own name being jakkul
and his overall design being very horror
inspired this is exactly why I think
kage know me Moria is devil fruit would
suit him pretty well there's another
perfect fruit for mihawk in the series
but let's go one at a time with kage
Nomi mihawk could collect the shadows of
all people he takes down now since
mihawk is already insanely powerful he
wouldn't really need an army of Shadows
to defend him he would instead collect
them as trophies and to punish people
who are stupid enough to challenge him
this would also play well into the idea
of vampirism with mihawk's opponents
evaporated by sunlight when they lost a
duel okay this fruit is literally made
for me hot but what if I tell you that
another fruit May suit him even
betterbato Nomi model vampire you
probably think I'm making this fruit up
but it actually exists in the one piece
Universe specifically in the video game
unlimited World red the fruit literally
transforms the user into a vampire and
gives them the ability to teleport and
suck the life force from others since
the battle batonomi is not canon I won't
spend any more time talking about it but
it's surely my final pick for mihawk is
it's undeniably the one that suits in
the best kozuki olden Odin the legendary
son of wano managed to become one of the
most powerful men alive due to his
exceptional swordsmanship and hockey
control the first devil fruit I picked
for him may seem a bit weird to some of
you but it's actually the gorogoro know
me nl's devil fruit that allows its user
to manipulate and even transform into
lightning themselves so the reason I'd
give this fruit to Odin is because I
believe he's already strong enough
offensively and with the fruits logia
properties he would be completely
Invincible he would also be able to move
at lightning speeds and slash his
opponents without them even noticing
unless they have advanced observation
hockey developed the only way Odin could
lose a battle with this route is if the
enemy he's fighting is for some reason
immune to lightning like Livy was in his
battle against denel that said The more
fitting devil fruit for Odin
thematically would be the Ino inonomi
model okuchi no makami this mythical
Zone fruit would allow him to transform
into the guardian of wano an ancient
wolf deity this is thematically fitting
consider during Odin's Royal bloodline
in love for his Nation but also goes
well with his fighting style as Zone
fruit would Grant him enhanced strength
and speed without limiting him in any
way the ability to use ice attacks would
be a cherry on top but honestly I don't
see Odin using it that much as he'd
probably like to retain his Samurai
fighting style so which of these two
fruits would be better suited for Odin
well since we're trying to make
characters as strong as possible by
giving them devil fruits I think annel's
fruit is a better choice as it's
considered one of the Invincible fruits
in the world with half of the characters
covered we're finally ready to talk
about the one and only red-haired Shanks
Shanks is arguably the strongest Emperor
currently in the series although we have
really limited information about him we
know that he has Mastery of all forms of
hockey especially conquerors the most
powerful one what's interesting about
the red hair Pirates is that they're the
only known crew in the series in which
not a single member has devil fruit
abilities so what if they're already
insanely overpowered Captain had one
which one would it be okay let's start
by pairing him with one of the devil
fruits his fellow Emperor has
Blackbeard's yummy yummy know me this
lokia type devil fruit would Grant him
the power of Darkness essentially
allowing him to nullify other devil
fruit powers and absorb things around
him like a black hole if you're
wondering why I'm giving Shanks this
specific devil fruit there's a simple
reason for that Shanks is primarily a
hockey-based fighter relying on his
powerful conquerors hockey birds to
completely paralyze his opponents
imagine a man like that also having the
power to nullify other people's fruits
he'd be unstoppable it's also possible
that Shanks could use this fruit to send
smaller black holes to suck in his
opponent's weapons and equipment even
the likes of the Admirals would stand no
chance against him as their strong logia
devil fruits would be pretty much
useless and they'd have to fight him
using only hockey and let's just say
that wouldn't go very well for them
another devil fruit that would suit
Shanks perfectly is magumugunomi also
belonging to one of his adversaries the
Marine Fleet Admiral Akainu this devil
fruit was stated by Oda the creator of
one piece to be the one with the highest
defensive capabilities in the world it
allows the user to turn into and control
the boiling hot magma which would also
look pretty cool with Shane's red hair
and overall appearance of course just
looking good will unfortunately not cut
it for this video so let's see what it
would bring to the table in terms of
combat during the Marine Fort Arc we
were shown that akinu can use this devil
fruit to shoot the magma out of his
hands it's similar to the volcano
erupting based on this it's only natural
that Shanks could do it too most likely
firing a big burst off of magma when he
swings his sword like with other logia
devil fruits it would make him much
faster and harder to hit and he could
just turn into magma in disappearing
seconds another advantage of this fruit
is its Simplicity Shanks doesn't need to
fly or turn into some kind of monster to
be strong he just needs a strong offense
of devil fruit that won't get in his way
while in combat and that's why I'm
picking magumugunomi is the best suited
devil fruit for Shanks Monkey D GARP
GARP is an absolute Powerhouse and one
of the strongest Marines to ever live he
has incredible physical strength and
Mastery of hockey which we recently saw
in the manga when he completely
destroyed a part of the island with a
single punch the important thing to
mention is that GARP is not relying on
any weapons to help him battle he only
uses his bare fists therefore we need to
find a fruit that suits that fighting
style best again two devil fruits come
to mind and the first one is none other
than guragura numi the powerful Quakes
produced by this fruit along with garb's
punches would surely bring his strength
to the next level you may not agree with
me on this but I think this fruit is way
more suited for GARP than it ever was
for Whitebeard just think about it this
fruit can only be activated with the
user's hands meaning that when
Whitebeard is in the middle of the
battle and is holding his weapon he
can't really use it to its full
potential now imagine GARP throwing
punch after punch and each time
producing the incredibly powerful shock
waves that shake the entire Island that
they're on the destruction would be
unfathomable another interesting option
for GARP would be the unknown Dalmatian
zoen fruit which is owned by valleyside
Royal Dalmatian there's two reasons for
this first is that since GARP relies on
his physical strength in battles any
Zone fruit would be a perfect choice as
it would dramatically increase his
strength and wouldn't slow him down in
any way the second reason is that since
the show's beginning GARP was always
accompanied by the symbol of out usually
on his mask ship or shirt although it
would be really cool to see Garfield's a
dog themed fruit at the end of the day
Guru guranomi is obviously the best
choice when it comes to strength before
we explain which devil fruit would be
the most suited for dark King Rayleigh
let's first quickly cover Ben Beckman
Ben is one of the most respected men on
the Seas and the second in command of
the red-haired Pirates as with other
crew members he has no devil fruit but
it was confirmed that he's very skilled
in using hockey so much so that he can
even Infuse bullets with it now since we
know very little about Ben and his
specific abilities it was really hard to
find the right fruit for him but after
some research I think I finally found it
and I'm sure you weren't expecting this
one so in my opinion the best route for
Ben Beckman is Foxy's fruit
okay I know you're a bit confused but
hear me out this devil fruit essentially
allows its users to slow down every
object they touch for 30 seconds with
that in mind Ben could use this ability
to slow down any attack that comes his
way and maybe even opponents themselves
if we combine this ability with his
hockey use bullets Ben should in theory
be able to shoot any opponent
effortlessly and since they're slowed
they wouldn't have a way to dodge it
it's also important to mention that
dudiben's experience he would surely use
the fruit much better than foxy did and
could even develop some unique abilities
like slowing down multiple enemies at
the same time or creating some sort of
barrier around him so everyone who comes
close gets slowed down Silver's Rayleigh
Rayleigh or as he's more commonly known
the dark King was the Vice Captain of
the Legendary Pirate King's crew and one
of the strongest characters in the
entire series like many other big shots
on this list he doesn't need a devil
fruit but there's actually one I'd
really like to see him use the
Blackbeard's fruit the yummy yummy no me
I mean first of all he's literally the
dark King so just imagine how cool it
would be if he also possessed a Darkness
devil fruit to go with that secondly as
we already mentioned in Shang segment
this lokia devil fruit is probably the
strongest one as it nullifies other
fruits and can serve as a Vortex to drag
things into it although Rayleigh is a
master of hockey he still struggled
against Admiral kizado during the
celebrity Arc and if the battle was
prolonged he would probably have lost
therefore having this devil fruit to
even the playing field and disable other
people's abilities would be incredibly
beneficial to him as he could go
toe-to-toe with any enemy to be honest I
feel like pretty much any bogia type
fruit would make Rayleigh and Stanley
strong but I just couldn't miss out on
the opportunity to give him the dark one
click on this video where we explained
what would happen if all straw hats
attacked gear 5 Luffy together